scheiße jetzt sehe ich eher aus wie eine
chipstüte läuft hey leute was geht ab
und herzlich willkommen beim neuen video
heute geht's einfach mal um die fünf
dinge die wirklich jeder zocker kennt
ich wünsche mir natürlich viel spaß mit
diesem video und ich würde einfach mal
sagen wir fangen mit nummer eins am
mittwoch so man ist schon etwas länger
nicht mehr aufs klo gehen aber es kommt
einfach nicht so vor als ob man jetzt
auf die toilette müssen
aber sobald man die xbox playstation pc
game boy was möchte ich auch immer ein
gemacht hat passiert folgendes da machen
wir mal schnell weiter mit nummer zwei
vor allem die online gamer sollten diese
sache eigentlich relativ gut kennen man
geht ganz normal in ein game rein und
genau in eurem team sind natürlich
wieder diese achtjährigen ttc spiel noch
lange nicht spielen dürfen aber diese
achtjährigen hardcore zocker die
wahrscheinlich irgendwann mal bei rtl
landen werden haben es irgendwie
hinbekommen ihr scheiß mikrofon
anzuschließen und das hört sich dann
natürlich so an keine award die zu hause
geschlagen werden oder was weiß ich aber
passiert halt alter du scheißt kind
einfach mal die fresse halten
ich bin einmal in ruhe zocken guck mal
überschlafen nummer drei was viele
zocker auch kennen sollten ist folgende
situation gemacht nach einem game dass
ihr gerade weil soeben zu ende gezockt
hab einfach die konsole aus und fragt
euch zwei sekunden später warum mir das
überhaupt getan habt ich habe wenig zu
tun kann ja weiter zocken so als
nächstes bei mir ist es zumindest so
immer wenn ich irgendwas zocke dann er
sich dabei meistens chips und nach
kurzer zeit die mein controller schon so
aus also meine xbox jetzt sieht meinen
controller schon so aus wie die zweite
chips hypo sag mal ich denke mal die
zocker unter euch sol.de
wir wollten ja so als letzter noch jeder
zocker hat ja so manchmal seine paar
minuten in denen er sich einfach nicht
kontrollieren kann
und irgendwelche unschönen wörter von
sich gibt bei manchen ist extremer wenn
man sich nicht so aber irgendwie kommt
auch immer der gleiche
games counterstrike und kempers fahrt
über die märkte weiter so lädt das war's
dann auch schon wieder mit diesem video
ich hoffe es hat euch wie immer gefallen
und ja einen daumen hoch tools immer mal
gucken ob wir bei diesem video wieder
die 100 knacken bin ich relativ
zuversichtlich wenn sie nicht so
gefallen hat dann gibt natürlich auch
einen daumen nach unten bin ich auch
zufrieden des ladies open mic und ja
facebook instagram blabla alles und in
der video beschreibung hier unten kommt
ihr zu meinem letzten video
dort habe ich in drei minuten so viele
fragen wie möglich beantwortet und juden
kommt hier noch mal zu meinem vorletzten
video
dort ging es um die menschheit dass wir
verblöden und lange war schaut sie
einfach beides an wenn ihr bock haft und
abonnieren nicht vergessen hier oben und
wir sehen uns an der nächsten mal nötig